where is that family now
which improvised line turned out to be
one of the best jokes in the entire
black widow film
the marvel movie is full of incredible
relationships and dynamics between the
main characters
and a big reason for it is how much the
team improvised together
how did florence pugh end up ruining
scarlett johansson's ego
all the time all that time that i spent
posing i was trying to actually do
something good
fan favorite florence pugh brought a
whole lot of energy and fun to the black
widow set
one of her funniest lines was an improv
from the actress herself
inspired by a conversation with some of
the stunt people on the film
when pew was working with the stunt
coordinators she'd started considering
what her landing poses could be
the yelena actress wanted to do her best
and asked whether or not her poses could
be achieved realistically
only to learn that none of the superhero
poses are actually all that practical
it was then confirmed that if scarlett
johansson actually landed in her black
widow poses
she would end up breaking some bones
once pugh got wind of the truth
she had to confer with johansen about
this odd and hilarious fact
while the two of them were discussing
the unfortunate reality of superhero
poses
writer eric pearson overheard the women
and knew they'd struck gold with it
so he decided to have them add the joke
into the script
according to johansen florence pugh had
managed to ruin the ego of the black
widow actress and
other mcu cast members in just 15
minutes
it's a fighting pose you're a total
poser
when it came to reading the black widow
script before filming
director kate shortland along with
actors scarlett johansson and florence
pew
all found themselves groaning at one
particular moment
the script had a joke about yelena's
time of the month being the reason for
her being moody
at least according to david harper's red
guardian these women didn't just want to
let it slide and indulge in the
misogynistic joke
so they took matters into their own
hands and whipped out some sassy and
powerful lines of their own
hugh comes back at david harbor's
character i don't get my period
i don't have a uterus this of course is
in reference to the fact that elena
natasha romanov along with all the other
widows were sterilized so they couldn't
have children
the comeback doesn't end there though as
pew herself said
she unleashed all the gruesome details
in great detail with johansen's support
not only did this improv make a point
about the misogynistic comment
is it your time of the month the actors
managed to bring up an uncomfortable
trauma in a really fun joking way
david harbour was notorious for
improvising on the set of black widow
and it really helped amplify his
character and the script
some of his best moments came out on the
spot including
the dinner scene if it seems strange
that the writers had him talking about
santa claus
when you told them that they could stay
up late to catch santa claus
it's because none of that was part of
the original script
a reason as to why the dynamics on set
were so strong was because the actors
and director did a lot of character work
and development
instead of just diving into performing
the actors tackled their scripts
together and explored the relationship
dynamics between all of them
while some golden moments were born from
improvisations
harper credits the writer for delivering
an extremely strong script for the team
to bring to life
director kate shortland gave the actors
enough freedom to enhance the script
while honoring the already great story
the writers had created
you wait for him and then when the
cookies are gone
then you see he's there one other david
harbor idea
led to a touching and tender scene
including one very famous
classic song american pie the song
wasn't mentioned in the script initially
but the actor's proposition was just too
special not to include
at one point elena was meant to send red
guardian away leaving him with one thing
to say and then be gone
but then harper had the idea of this
story coming from their past
the deceivingly normal image driving and
playing the song to keep elena calm when
she was young allows us to see
just how deep the relationship between
the two characters is
as well as how the song became a
significant part of yelena's history
their ability to reconnect for just a
small and sweet moment
wound up being one of the most poignant
in the whole film
you smell really bad the helicopter
scene was filled with
way more ad-libbing than we could have
expected aside from pew and johansson
whipping out their sassy remarks
david harbour was improvising like a
demon
according to shortland this was pretty
well the norm for the actor in his
scenes
but this moment in particular was packed
with loads of gems made up on the spot
you know i want the party to feel
actually like a party this is yet
another example of how beneficial the
work the actors did together before
filming was
their passion and joy working together
really comes through
i have no idea the amount of character
work and relationship building the team
did
is evident and part of the reason the
characters resonate with us so much
their dynamics are totally believable
and the comedy
makes us love it even more which
improvise scene was your favorite
you